now the oscar-winning director steve
mcqueen known for films such as 12 years
as slave and hunger
is back with an anthology of films
focusing on the west indian community in
london
starring john boyega and latisha wright
the films are a mix of true
and fictional stories that celebrate the
community's ability to achieve against
the odds
mcqueen sat down with skies julian
joseph to talk about his new film series
and the inspiration behind it as
individuals
we have impossible back
[Music]
as a collective we stand a chance
[Applause]
i needed to sort of see and experience
you know my my history the things
which i was sort of which i grew up with
in the uk
and i thought they you know i saw they
weren't being sort of
portrayed on screen and so therefore
there was a hole
in the narrative of a british film or
and and therefore
that was my my my want need i needed
them i needed there to be a films
within that sort of journey within that
trajectory what did you see
that was lacking what what are the
experiences that that you grew up with
that you didn't see portrayed
on the screen normal families normal
black families from that time
you know um things which are going on i
mean you know
the fact that um one would brush their
teeth and not think of the fact that
they happen to be black i mean that
wasn't even interesting
in the way just says you know other
people didn't think about their
ethnicity because we had things to do
you know we had families we had to go to
work and so forth and whatnot just the
normal things in life absolutely
the film's focus on a series of um
historical events that highlight
uh police brutality injustice racism
um themes that have been brought to the
fore again
with the resurgence of black lives
matter do you think that
anything has changed from the time in
which your your films are set
well i will make it clear as well
there's the the there's all the joy in
in these films as well there's
there's one thing called lovers rock
which is just about partying
but two people falling in love um but
but again
there's a context of of what a lot of
struggles
the western community have actually sort
of deal with um
and you know with the police and
authorities and so forth even just as
over having a fair
sort of uh a crack at work so it's just
one of those things which
you know again we like to struggle with
um and i just wanted to sort of
look and look at those things and i
think the thing with george floyd of
course that is high
that has risen the temperature on all of
this
so in a way it's it's it it's it's it's
um
it's a kind of a good place to to
re-examine our past and and look at
where we need to go in in the future
particularly with them mangrove does it
surprise you that many people
will not have known of that history at
all yes
uh it's a it's a pride how that has been
swept through the carpet i don't know
everyone should it's like was a there
was a landmark case
uh i'm just i'm just happy that we will
be at what we were able to put this on
the big screen so now that everybody's
not choosing
the people know about that trial and
also know
about repercussions it had on on every
everyday life for everybody
the only thing i would want people to
come away with is is a sense of
uh of community be it whatever
background you're from i mean it's you
know
and that's that's the whole idea of
small acts you know individually
we could do only so much but as a
collective as as as
as as a you as a community we could do
so so so much more
i mean this is about united kingdom this
is about us whoever we us
is whatever background we're from it's
about how we
uh come together and and make progress
because again you know we could do
anything